même à -15° il quitte son ch celle des
dans la neige en chaise roulante il se
rend au parc à côté sébastien smet et
fument chaque jour un joint de cannabis
pour dit-il calmer les douleurs dues à
son handicap c'est pas un manège
nécessairement agréable à faire à tous
les jours mais force force oblige à agir
comme ça pour l'instant impossible de
fumer du cannabis dans son ch et celle
des mais il souhaite pouvoir fumer dans
le csld lorsque le cannabis sera
légalisée échouer le projet de loi
permettrait qu'on aménage un fumoir pour
le cannabis dans des établissements
comme les ch et celle des lorsque la
substance sera légalisée mais beaucoup
de questions demain et à certains csld
qui ont un fumoir à est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il va y avoir permission de
fumer également de consommer le cannabis
en même temps dans la même endroit est
ce que en vo on va mettre des heures
différentes
on fait quoi avec les crs celle d où il
y en a plus de fumoirs nous on a un
fumoir s'était depuis la construction et
les foyers privés appelés ressources
intermédiaires qui accueille des gens
semi autonomes pourraient aussi avoir
des fumoirs pour le cannabis parce
qu'elle redémarre pour re consommation
du cannabis puis de rose or la
consommation du tabac
il ya des choses qui se ménage mais
c'est clair que ça ne va me prendre des
orientations plus clair qu'est ce qu'on
a maintenant en ce moment on est dans le
flou total on attend et dans les
résidences pour personnes âgées
autonomes
on veut plutôt interdire de fumer le
cannabis dans les règlements d'immeubles
inclure des restrictions pour éviter la
consommation de cannabis dans les lieux
communs des résidences et pour les
appartements les résidences pour aînés
s'inquiète des incidences que comporte
la fumée de cannabis entre autres quant
à l'impact sur la cohabitation entre
résident les propriétaires doivent agir
rapidement pour interdire le cannabis
avant c'est l'égalisation en juillet ils
ont jusqu'à jusqu'à la plupart jusqu'à
la fin mars pour procéder au
renouvellement a fait des beaux donc ils
incluent à l'égard de la nouvelle
réglementation qui sera en vigueur pour
l'immeuble à compter du 1er juillet une
interdiction complète au niveau du
cannabis québec précise que
l'installation de fumoirs dans les
résidences sera possible mais en aucun
cas obligatoire
le ch est celle des deux sébastien smic
pourrait donc décider de ne pas en
aménager je trouverais saut et je
souhaite